europe's energy crunch is fueling
tensions with russia
moscow has denied restricting gas
deliveries to its neighbors insisting
they're to blame for their own problems
a key natural gas pipeline has been
running in reverse from germany to
poland after russia stopped flows in the
other direction meanwhile western europe
is sourcing extra supplies from the u.s
as the energy crisis deepens
this earthquake in northern holland was
recorded on surveillance cameras over 70
quakes have been recorded and groaning
in this year
court fossen still remembers one strong
quake in 2012.
i was sitting behind my desk
on a desk chair with with wheels
underneath and i was moving forward and
backward for about 20 centimeters so i
was really shaking what's happening here
fossen belongs to a citizens initiative
that blames natural gas production for
the constant earthquakes that's why
pumping stations are being gradually
shut down in 2023 production will stop
completely because the damage is only
getting worse
is that the cost of strengthening
strengthening houses in order to be able
to continue gas extraction was rising
too much
and the third is that the gas field is
for eighty ninety percent empty at this
moment
the netherlands will soon stop being a
major gas supplier the country will even
have to import gas itself from places
like the gas storage facility in raiden
in lower saxony
here gas is stored underground mainly
from russia but because gas storage
facilities are only half full gas market
experts are worried
the gas levels are already very low they
have not been this low at this time of
year in the last 10 years and because it
has been cold in the last few days and
cold weather is forecasted for january
the storage facilities are emptying
relatively quickly this is a situation
that is already worrying market
participants you can see that in the
high prices
critics say gazprom which has close ties
to the kremlin is keeping delivery
volumes low in order to put pressure on
the eu
that spat stems from the eu position on
the ukraine conflict and the slow
approval pace of the controversial
nordstream 2 baltic sea pipeline
the situation is worsening for over a
week gasprom has not sent natural gas
via the critical yamal pipeline to this
pumping station in brandenburg
prices are so high now that we are
actually worried about the security of
gas supplies
strategic restraint no longer makes
sense here and we are actually
destroying our prospects as a reliable
gas supplier for the next few years
doubts around gazprom's reliability are
growing as are fears that russia's
president putin will use natural gas as
a bargaining chip in the future
a potential ace up his sleeve in this
political poker game with the european
union
you